lady gaga teases us with cryptic  Instagram posts could this mean new  music is on the way the 32 year old  singer has never been shy about  flaunting her bod for the world to see  but her recent nearly nude Instagram  posts by Eli Russell Lynette's have got  fans questioning the reasoning behind  the photos in the images the blonde  bombshell is either putting on or simply  posing in sheer stockings her tattoos on  full display so what is Gaga promoting  to these images be for a new edgy photo  spread  or is she evolving into her next persona  following her singer-songwriter phase  with her 2016 album Joann guess we'll  just have to wait and see what the  Grammy winner has up her sleeve no  matter who you are you change the world  by sharing your stories with other  people  [Music]